yes you do because this is so cute so
sweet thank you you just you showed up
showed out today I'm showing up and
showing out I know well the way to do it
well Elaine I don't know what to talk to
about I don't know what to talk to you
about first sis your six nominations the
most nominated tonight your performance
or maybe Duck hit in the garbage
yep yep I brought me a hot date tonight
I sure did I mean he's looking like a a
snack over there ain't he a little snack
of a cowboy I know I'm like you know
what I said you can be my date but you
can't steal my thunder so
he was so cute you were like smile honey
and I was like hey look look at all
these cameras don't be nervous boy he
did all right well tonight you got six
nominations but I got to ask you how
many bell bottoms do you own now what's
the count coming in on that it's
embarrassing honestly I'm telling you
like way too many actually I don't know
if there's such thing as way too many
bottles there are there's no such thing
as that and there is no such thing as
too many nominations for you you deserve
all the praise you're receiving this
this year and we're going to see it
perform tonight yeah a little Birdie's
telling me maybe a little jelly in a
roll might be joining you I mean that's
what I've heard yeah I'm telling you I'm
so excited and two he is one of my
favorite people on the face of the Earth
he has a story to tell and that's what
I'm all about I'm just like you know
what there's all kinds of cons and we
need to tell our stories that way people
can and relate to them and he's got such
a relatable Story I mean he's just good
people and honey out we could a lot of
us were relating and we're tuning in for
your story on Yellowstone we've all been
been on pins and needles about the Fate
for Yellowstone whether or not it's
coming back is it coming back you're
telling me a no no no girl I know you
got the Intel no what is the deal that's
the thing is I realized that the TV
business is even crazier than the music
business isn't it I know I'm like I mean
no matter which direction it goes it's
going to be incredible because Taylor
shared and I mean he's just he can do no
wrong in my opinion
um but yeah I'm waiting for that call
I'm like y'all let me know when to be
there and I'll be there how is Kevin
riding off into the Sunset Lane oh my
gosh well first of all it's Kevin
Costner I mean don't even get me started
I know don't even get me started but I I
think he's just incredible himself too
so yeah well I look forward to seeing
you backstage after you've collected a
trophy or two just saying and Doug can
come back and party come back yeah he's
cool we'll let him in our crowd have fun
foreign